in the midst of scandal after scandal
from the Trump campaign though and we've
talked about the rape trial we've talked
about the sexual assault allegations
there's a whole other issue that Donald
Trump is having right now it can be sort
of easy to get away from the more
traditional predictors of how an
election will go when one of the
nominees is being accused by countless
women of sexually assaulting them and
making fun of disabled people and
ridiculing or anybody that you can
imagine but there's a bigger picture
problem that Donald Trump has one of
these issues is President Obama's
approval rating generally speaking a
high approval rating for the president
that's in office tends to be better for
the presidential candidate of the same
party so in this case President Obama is
a Democrat a fact that is probably not
lost on many in our audience as a result
a good approval rating for President
Obama is better for Hillary Clinton also
running as a Democrat as it happens
President Obama's approval rating has
hit a new high there is a recent CNN RC
poll where the president's approval
rating has hit 55% this is the highest
mark of the entire second term and it
ties the high mark from President
Obama's first term this is continuing
continuing a really strong streak for
President Obama of an up ticking
approval rating a year ago at this time
it was about 10 points lower than it is
now and one interesting internal
statistic is that if we look just among
white voters President Obama does much
better with educated white voters than
he does with uneducated white voters
right 55% of whites with college degrees
approve of President Obama's work as
president only 44% of whites without
college degrees like the job that
President Obama is doing so this is very
very interesting and this is above and
beyond the personal and specific Trump
scandals if people are buying large
happy with President Obama and I know
55% sounds like barely more than half
but in the polarized world we live in
fifty five percent is really good that
helps Hillary
Clinton doesn't it yeah 55% for
presidential approval numbers is pretty
high and I think part of it too is
people are seeing the next two potential
presidential candidates Trump and
Clinton and they're like well maybe we
could just have four more years of Obama
that would be preferable a lot of trumps
campaign has been centered around
accusing Hillary Clinton of promising
four more years of President Obama now
in some areas that's more true in some
areas that's less true but when four
years of President Obama or in this case
eight years of President Obama are
ranked pretty favorably by voters
there's not much of an advantage to
running against the Obama record and
this is not my opinion personally I've
had countless critiques of the Obama
administration and we've covered those
four nearly eight years but from a
purely mathematical standpoint when the
president is relatively well liked
that's not a good situation to run
against the president's record as a way
of running against your opponent now in
spite of having aggressive and spiteful
haters and President Obama has as many
of those I think it's pretty clear at
this point that President Obama's
presidency will be seen by history books
as impactful and in many ways very
positive and I know that that angers the
haters I know that progressives real
progressives have significant issues
with much of what President Obama has
done in many areas that is not what I am
talking about what I am saying is in the
context of what presidents can do and
what presidents have done it's getting
harder to make the objective case that
President Obama's two terms will be seen
as a real failure the economy
significantly rebounding the standing of
the u.s. around the world significantly
rebounding from the embarrassing status
under the George W Bush administration
progress when it comes to many social
issues significant changes in terms of
foreign policy at least in terms of
troops around the world even though of
course we have seen Isis rise in the
wake of the hairbrained decision by
George W Bush to go into Iraq I have no
doubt
and all we can do is wait and see if
history vindicates what I'm saying that
historically President Obama is going to
be seen as an effective president aside
from whether you agree with his politics
send me your thoughts on that I'm up on
Twitter at D Pakman we will take a break
and be back with more after this
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing